[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
willkommen alles Wichtige vom Sport hat
Norbert Lehmann für Sie
als erstes geht unser Blick in die
Ukraine
zum ersten Mal in der umkämpften
Ostukraine Außenministerin bärburg nennt
die Großstadt hakef ein Sinnbild für den
Irrsinn des russischen Angriffskrieges
mehr Geld für knappe Kinderarzt nein für
rund 180 Medikamente werden die
Festbeträge drei Monate lang ausgesetzt
die Pharma-Branche bleibt skeptisch
und Deal im grüne gewölbeprozess
Dresdner Gericht schlägt geringere
Strafen gegen Geständnisse und Rückgabe
eines Teils der gestohlenen
Schmuckstücke vor
bei ihrem Besuch in der Ostukraine hat
Außenministerin bärburg dem Land weitere
Waffenlieferungen zugesagt Werbung ist
das erste Kabinettsmitglied das nach
hackefrei ist aus Sicherheitsgründen
wurde Ihr Besuch zunächst geheim
gehalten
harkev zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine
geriet schon mit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges unter starken Beschuss
im September drängte dann die
ukrainische Armee die russischen Truppen
aus dem Gebiet zurück doch die Lage rund
um brake bleibt angespannt Tim Krüger
berichtet
Ankunft mit dem Zug nur etwas mehr als
vier Stunden wird die deutsche
Außenministerin in der zweitgrößten
ukrainischen Stadt bleiben Zeit genug
dennoch um die Wunden zu sehen die der
Krieg in Raki hinterlassen hat erste
Station ein Umspannwerk das vor wenigen
Wochen erst von russischen Raketen
getroffen wurde
bei wie viel Haushalten fällt jetzt der
Strom aus oder wie viel Prozent der
Stromversorgung sind dadurch betroffen
man arbeite am Rande der Möglichkeiten
erklärt ihr der Gouverneur und schalte
auf andere Umspannwerke um
die Energieversorgung ist noch immer
eine Herausforderung in der geschundenen
Stadt nur etwa 40 km ist die russische
Grenze von hier entfernt rakiv war eines
der ersten Ziele gleich nach
Kriegsbeginn
für eine Stadt belagert zerschossen
befreit spiegelt die ganze Furchtbarkeit
dieses brutalen russischen
Angriffskrieges wieder aber eben auch
den ganzen Mut die Widerstandsfähigkeit
und damit die Hoffnung für die Ukraine
auf ein Leben in Frieden noch aber toben
erbitterte Kämpfe etwa in bachmut in
Solidar das ist nur etwas mehr als 200
km entfernt von bearbox besuchsort und
so begleitet die Außenministerin auch
die Debatte um die Lieferung von
deutschen Kampfpanzern wir brauchen
diese Panzer um unsere Städte und unsere
Dörfer befreien zu können die sich unter
russischer Besatzung befinden
weitere Waffenlieferungen zu allerdings
ohne konkret auf Kampfpanzer einzugehen
Werbung hat sich öffentlich also nicht
konkret zu Kampfpanzern geäußert Tim
Kröger in rakev aber hinter den Kulissen
haben bärbock und die ukrainische
Kollegin ja über das Thema weitere
Waffenlieferung gesprochen
absolut Waffenlieferungen waren hier ein
Thema an der Lena Babak die deutsche
Außenministerin und ihr ukrainischer
Amtskollege Kleber sind ja zusammen mit
dem Zug von Kiew nach gefahren und
hatten dabei Gelegenheit länger
miteinander zu sprechen allerdings hat
eben Annalena baerbock hier keine
konkreten Zusagen zu Kampfpanzern
gemacht aber sie hat ja hier in Haake
die Folgen des Krieges gesehen sie hat
das Leiden der Menschen gesehen und
vielleicht bringt das noch mal neuen
Schwung in die Diskussion um die
Lieferung von deutschen an die Ukraine
ihr ukrainischer Außenminister Kollege
Kollege jedenfalls hat hier noch mal
Druck gemacht er hat gesagt im Grunde
weiß die Bundesregierung in ihrem
Inneren ja schon dass es zu einer
solchen Entscheidung zugunsten vom
Kampfpanzern kommen muss aber er hat
auch gewarnt er hat gesagt eine solche
Entscheidung darf eben nicht zu spät
kommen ganz einfach deswegen weil hier
in der Ukraine jeden Tag Menschen
sterben danke dem Krüger
ZDF heute live spricht um 19.30 mit
ex-nato-general Egon Rams über neue
russische Vorstöße in der Ostukraine in
der ZDF heute-media-kanälen
der russische Angriff auf die Ukraine
hat auch Folgen für das Verhältnis von
NATO und EU beide wollen noch enger
zusammenarbeiten eine Erklärung dazu
unterzeichneten heute
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
und EU-Ratspräsident Michelle wie die
stärkere Kooperation aussehen soll das
zeigt Ihnen Florian
ein Besuch am anderen Ende Brüssels die
Spitzen der EU im Hauptquartier der NATO
ihr letzter Auftritt an dieser Stelle
war am Tag des russischen Einmarsches in
die Ukraine fast ein Jahr später geht es
immer noch um den Krieg und darum wie EU
und NATO angesichts dessen besser
zusammenarbeiten
wir sind entschlossen die Partnerschaft
zwischen der NATO und der Europäischen
Union auf eine neue Stufe zu heben
zum Beispiel beim Schutz der kritischen
Infrastruktur in Fragen der
militärischen Sicherheit aber das wird
in der Erklärung von heute auch deutlich
verlässt Europa sich weiter auf die
Allianz die von der militärischen Macht
der USA abhängt Zitat die NATO bleibt
die Grundlage kollektiver Verteidigung
und entscheidend für die EURO
atlantische Sicherheit
entscheidend für die Sicherheit weltweit
sei so die Botschaft heute die Ukraine
weiter zu unterstützen und so ist auch
hier die Frage gegenwärtig was der
Westen noch liefern kann auch
Kampfpanzer
Großbritannien könnte laut
Medienberichten demnächst als erstes
Land überhaupt an den westlichen
Kampfpanzer den Challenger too in die
Ukraine schicken in Brüssel ist es die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin die heute
dasselbe von anderen fordert
die Ukraine sollte alles an
militärischer Ausrüstung erhalten was
das Land zur Verteidigung benötigt und
womit es umgehen kann es ist eine
Botschaft Richtung Deutschland dessen
Regierung noch zögert den Kampfpanzer
Leopard 2 zu liefern doch der Druck auf
Berlin Weg wächst
einige Arzneimittel wie Fiebersaft für
Kinder sind in Deutschland ja zurzeit
schwer zu bekommen nun setzt der
Spitzenverband der gesetzlichen
Krankenkassen auf folgende Maßnahme für
bestimmte kindermedikamente können die
Krankenkassen den Herstellern ab dem
ersten Februar vorübergehend mehr Geld
zahlen dadurch soll es sich für
pharmaform mehr lohnen nach Deutschland
zu liefern die Reaktion skeptisch dann
die panzen berichtet deutsche die über
die niederländische Grenze fahren um
dort Medikamente für Kinder zu kaufen
das wurde im Dezember mit den je
Realität auch wenn das
Infektionsgeschehen hier nun vielerorts
zurückgeht bleiben als erhebliche
Engpässe bei den nationalen vor allem
auch Antibiotika das führt dann dazu
dass Krankheiten nicht mehr adäquat
behandelt werden können das führt dazu
dass Resistenzen vermehrt auftreten
werden und das ist etwas was in dieser
Form so noch nicht aufgetreten ist und
auch nicht akzeptabel ist nun der
Vorstoss des GKV Spitzenverband das bei
bestimmten fertig Arzneimitteln mit den
Wirkstoffen Ibuprofen und Paracetamol
und für Antibiotika die bisher geltenden
preisdeckel ausgesetzt werden ab Februar
für drei Monate sprich die Hersteller
können dann mehr Geld mit ihren Arzneien
in Deutschland verdienen dadurch soll
wieder mehr auf den deutschen Markt
kommen theoretisch
in der Hand haben es ganz allein die
Arzneimittelhersteller die müssen
produzieren und die müssen ausliefern
was wir machen können ist an den
Rahmenbedingungen eine Kleinigkeit
ändern das haben wir jetzt gemacht für
drei Monate durch das Aussetzen der
Arzneimittel Festbeträge aber Regale
füllen das kann nur die Farbenindustrie
ob die aber nun tatsächlich kurzfristig
mehr Produkte auf den deutschen Markt
umleitet fraglich Skepsis bei den
deutschen Herstellern unsere Unternehmen
produzieren derzeit rund um die Uhr es
gibt keine wahre die kurzfristig auf den
Markt kommen könnte nur weil sich der
Preis für drei Monate erhöht inwieweit
der heutige Vorstoß also hilft
kurzfristig die Regale zu füllen muss
ich noch zeigen wichtig sein so auch die
Kassen dass die avisierte langfristige
Änderung per Gesetz nun schnell
umgesetzt werde hierzu hatte der
Gesundheitsminister kurz vor Weihnachten
ein Eckpunkte Papier vorgelegt bis Ende
Januar soll daraus einen Gesetzentwurf
werden
festvertrags Bundeskanzler Scholz hatte
für heute zum mobilitätsgipfel geladen
und dabei wurde einmal mehr klar dass
nichts klar ist bei der Frage wie die
Mobilität in Zukunft aussehen muss vor
allem grün und FDP liegen über Kreuz die
Grünen wollen keine neuen Fernstraßen
die FDP sehr wohl Fahrrad und
bahnverbände kritisieren es gehen nach
wie vor zu sehr ums Auto Christiane
hübscher die die nicht eingeladen sind
protestieren draußen vor dem Kanzleramt
das sei kein mobilitätsgipfel sondern
eben doch wieder ein reiner autogipfel
hochkarätig aber einseitig besetzt neben
Bundeskanzler Scholz sind gleich fünf
Fachminister dabei dazu der
Ministerpräsident des autolandes
Niedersachsen und die drei großen
Automobilhersteller viele andere müssen
draußen bleiben und sollen sich gedulden
ganz wichtig wäre es gewesen den
Fußverkehr Radverkehr Busverkehr und
natürlich den Schienenverkehr mit
einzuladen und das ist im Grunde das
Hauptproblem das jetzt gesagt wird wir
werden dass alle so ein nach dem anderen
schön an den Tisch einladen und man das
ganze nicht im großen Ganzen zusammen
denkt wie die ganz große Verkehrswende
gelingen soll darüber streiten vor allem
Grüne und FDP immer wieder die Liberalen
wollen weiter auch neue Autobahnen bauen
die Grünen sind strikt dagegen wo bin
ich erstmal sanieren was wir da haben
bevor wir gerade in einem Land mit einer
solchen Dichte von straßennetzen darüber
reden dass wir jetzt neue Straßen
brauchen auf der Agenda heute erneut die
Elektromobilität noch immer kaufen die
Deutschen zu wenig Elektroautos vor
allem wohl weil der Ausbau von
Ladesäulen zu langsam vorankommt und
auch hier ist die Bundesregierung uneins
die FDP will dem verbrenner motor
möglichst weiter ein Türchen offenhalten
beispielsweise mit der ungewissen
Aussicht auf klimaneutrales
für die Zukunft der Mobilität ist das
Auto mit klimaneutralen Antrieben ganz
besonders wichtig
gleichzeitig hängen aber natürlich auch
zigtausende Arbeitsplätze in der
Automobilindustrie der Gipfel ist zu
Ende neue Beschlüsse brachte er nicht
Klimaschutz und verkehrstransformation
sind für die Ampel offenbar ein ebenso
dickes Brett wie für die
Vorgängerregierung
in Frankreich Unternehmen Präsident
macron und seine Regierung einen neuen
Anlauf ihre umstrittene Rentenreform
durchzusetzen
Premierministerin born legte Pläne vor
die bis 2030 eine Anhebung des
Renteneintrittsalters von 62 auf 64
Jahre vorsehen im Parlament fehlt
allerdings bisher die erforderliche
Mehrheit die Reform gilt in Frankreich
als äußerst und populär bereits vor zwei
Jahren gab es breiten Widerstand gegen
das Vorhaben
alle 4,4 Sekunden stirbt dein Kind auf
dieser Welt Hauptgrund in vielen armen
Ländern fehlt es an medizinischer
Versorgung die Folge Kinder sterben an
behandelbaren Krankheiten nach einer
un-schätzung waren das 2021 etwa 5
Millionen Kleinkinder und 2,1 Millionen
ältere Kinder Jugendliche und jung
Erwachsene besonders gefährdet seinen
Kinder in Südasien und südlich der
Sahara in Afrika in dieser Region ist
das Risiko eines frühen Todes 15 Mal
höher als in Europa oder Nordamerika
zurück nach Deutschland hier steht das
von der klimaschutzbewegung besetzte
dorf-lützerath kurz vor der Räumung der
Protest richtet sich gegen den
Kohleabbau durch den Energiekonzern RWE
wird zerrathmus dafür weichen über die
Lage vor Ort Peter Böhmer
geschlossener Polizeieinsatz Schreie von
Demonstrierenden
Rangeleien heute schon in Lutzerath
zwischen den klimaaktivisten und der
Polizei die mit massiven Kräften zur
Vorbereitung der Räumung Barrikaden
demontierte und Menschenketten auflöste
die klimaaktivisten entschlossen die
abbagerung des Örtchens lützerath mit
ein paar schon lange verlassenen Häusern
zu verhindern der Bundestag und viele
Nationen haben sich auf einen 1,5 Grad
sie verständlich und das war auch
parlamentarisches war auch demokratisch
und dann kann es nicht sein dass man
dann hier genau das Gegenteil macht und
ich glaube die Menschen sind bewusst was
in den nächsten Jahrzehnten auf die
Menschheit überhaupt zu kommen wenn es
weiter geht das Ende von Lutzerath ist
Teil eines Kompromisses der
schwarz-grünen Landesregierung und
juristisch ausgefochten fünf andere
Braunkohle Dörfer bleiben dafür erhalten
am Abend eine Bürgerversammlung mit
Lokalpolitik und Polizei erneut
lautstarke Diskussionen um Braunkohle
und Klimaziele
offen die Frage gewann die Räumung
startet seit heute ist die Rechtslage so
dass wir diese Räumung vornehmen könnten
weil zwei Gerichte zwei
Gerichtsinstanzen in allen Verfahren
diese Allgemeinverfügung und die Räumung
damit als offensichtlich rechtmäßig
befunden haben viele im Braunkohle
Revier erwarten dass die Räumung morgen
beginnt
beim Neujahrsempfang hat der
Bundespräsident die Gewalt in der
Silvesternacht verurteilt er forderte
meeresbeck gegenüber Polizei Feuerwehr
und Rettungskräften
Steinmeier ehrte auch 70 Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die sich besonders für das
Gemeinwohl einsetzen zwei Beispiele
Uschi bisams aus rheinland-
THW und DRK Mitarbeiter Martin Dietrich
aus Sachsen half im Erzgebirgskreis beim
Aufbau von Corona
die Freude war riesig als kurz vor
Weihnachten gestohlene Schmuckstücke aus
dem spektakulären Raub im weltberühmten
Grünen Gewölbe in Dresden auftauchten
zurückgegeben von den mutmaßlichen
Dieben offenbar als Pfand für mildere
Strafen bei der Fortsetzung des
Prozesses heute wurde klar die
Schmuckstücke sind zum Teil erheblich
beschädigt
angeklagt sind sechs junge Männer aus
der Berliner organisierten Kriminalität
Franziska wunderlich
ein Prozesstag der für viele Dresdner
und Kulturliebhaber ernüchternd war zwar
ist ein Teil der Juwelen aus dem Grünen
Gewölbe wieder aufgetaucht doch fast
alle Schmuckstücke haben Schaden
genommen wenn man sich das zusammenfasst
was heute die Restauratoren als Zeugin
hier vor Gericht gesagt hat dann ist
schon sehr viel beschädigt worden sie
hat gesagt ein zweistelliger
Millionenbetrag sei die Schadensumme so
wurde beispielsweise beim Bruststern des
polnischen weißen Adlers eine Spitze
abgetrennt auch gab es an einigen Teilen
feuchte Schäden 2 Tage lang suchten
deshalb Polizei Taucher in einem
Berliner Kanal nach weiteren Stücken
ohne Ergebnis bis heute fehlt unter
anderem die Toilette mit dem sächsischen
weißen einem Brillanten von fast 50
Karat die Angeklagten hatten lange
geschwiegen doch als die Beweislage
immer erdrückender wurde warfen sie ihr
Pfand in die Waagschale die Kronjuwelen
für mildere Haftstrafen
die Täter hinter Gitter zu bringen ist
sicherlich ein wichtiger Gesichtspunkt
aber hier ist sicherlich abzuwägen als
Alternative dass der Schmuck überhaupt
nicht zurückgekehrt wäre trotz des
beschädigten schmuckes verkündete das
Gericht am Nachmittag eine Verständigung
wenn die Angeklagten umfassend gestehen
drohen ihnen Haftstrafen zwischen vier
und knapp 7 Jahren also nur noch etwa
die Hälfte des Möglichen Strafmaßes
unterm Strich bietet für alle
Beteiligten diese Deal nur Vorteile die
Angeklagten kommen ein ganzes Stück
günstiger weg also Geständnis gegen
straf Rabatt die Ankläger und auch
natürlich die Richter haben weniger
Arbeit und die Öffentlichkeit hat ein
Großteil der Beute jedenfalls wieder
zurück die Mehrheit der Prozess
Beteiligten hat bereits heute dem
Vorschlag der Kammer zugestimmt
das Unwort des Jahres 2022 ist der
Begriff klimatauristen zur Begründung
erklärte die Jury aus
sprachwissenschaftler:innen damit würden
gewaltlose Protestformen zivilen
Ungehorsams in den Zusammenhang von
Gewalt und staatsfeindlichkeit gestellt
auf Platz 2
sozialtourismus das diskriminiere
kriegspflüchtlinge auf Platz drei setzte
die Jury Defensive Architektur ein
Ausdruck für eine Bauweise die
Obdachlose fernhalten soll
seit mehr als zwei Wochen wütendem
US-Bundesstaat Kalifornien heftige
Winterstürme erneut müssen tausende
Menschen ihre Häuser verlassen in
mehreren Regionen ordnen Behörden
Evakuierungen an zuvor war es durch
starke Regenfälle zu Überschwemmungen
und Erdrutschen gekommen insgesamt kam
mindestens 14 Menschen durch die Stürme
ums Leben 10.000 Haushalte sind ohne
Strom und um die Küstenstadt Center
Barbara wird vor Schlammlawine gewarnt
und wir kommen jetzt zur
Fußball-Bundesliga Norbert das erste
Dortmunder Testspiel im neuen Jahr gegen
Fortuna Düsseldorf
für den BVB war direkt beim Wechsel von
Amsterdam zur Borussia letzten Sommer
die Krebsdiagnose danach die monatelange
aber erfolgreiche Behandlung heute also
seine schwarz-gelbe Premiere
die Einwechslung des sigurischen
Nationalspielers ist für sein Team und
für die Fans des BVB die mit Abstand
wichtigste Zähne dieses Spiels und sie
alle hätten ihm sein erstes Tor für
Dortmund kurz vor Schluss von Herzen
gegönnt
habe ich mir heute noch aufgespart für
die Bundesliga und die Champions League
Torschütze in einem vom BVB dominierten
Spiel ist der eingewechselte Daniel
malen der mit seinem Solo zum 5:1
Endstand wichtige Punkte für den mit
Stars besetzten Dortmunder Sturm sammeln
kann trotzdem gehört die Schlagzeile des
Spiels der Premiere des chinesenen
Sebastian alle
ja das Schicksal Allers hat Deutschland
bewegt in den USA ist es der
Footballspieler derma Hamlin der
24-Jährige NFL Profi hatte vor einer
Woche in Cincinnati beim Spiel seiner
Buffalo Bills einen minutenlangen
Herzstillstand erlitten konnte aber
reanimiert werden seitdem große
Betroffenheit im ganzen Land seine
Rückennummer 3 wurde überall zum Symbol
der Anteilnahme ja und heute Nacht
konnte hermin das Krankenhaus
inszenierte verlassen und nachbarverlust
zurückkehren
und morgen beginnt die Handball-WM in
Polen und Schweden die deutsche
Mannschaft trifft am Freitag im ersten
Spiel auf Katha das DHB-Team mit letzten
Vorbereitungen im norddeutschen
Trainingslager
Bundestrainer Alfred gießlasson bitte
zur taktikstunde wer weiß ob in den
letzten Vorbereitungsspielen nicht doch
noch der entscheidende Kniff für den
großen Wurf bei der WM zu finden ist
schon viel Video schauen wahrscheinlich
jede
taktische Auslöser Handlungen die der
Gegner dann gespielt hat mindestens
einmal an und deshalb glaube ich wissen
wir da alle vor jedem Spiel sehr sehr
genau was auf uns zukommt nachdem die
Kollegen vom Fußball kürzlich nicht
geglänzt haben bietet sich den
Handballern die ziemlich gute Chance
eine deutsche Nationalmannschaft zu sein
die gut da steht
trau den vier Jungs viel zu den Jungs
dankeschön
zum Wetter regnerische mild geht es
weiter wo sie dennoch in der Nacht mit
Glätte rechnen sollten das erfahren Sie
gleich von Katja horneffer um 21.45
können Sie das heute schon mal sehen mit
Christian Sievers auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend kaum ist das eine Wolkenband
hier nach Osten abgezogen kommt schon
gleich das nächste Tief hinterher es
bleibt bei uns einfach regnerisch windig
und mild und so fällt heute auch
verbreitet Regen in der Nacht und zwar
von den Küsten bis zum Alpenrand und nur
in den östlichen Mittelgebirge und am
Alpenrand gibt's auch mal etwas Schnee
bevor der Regen ankommt kann es aber
auch noch mal Aufklaren und deswegen
werden die Straßen zum Teil glatt sein
zumindest in Bayern denn dort sinken die
Temperaturen auf 0 bis -4 Grad sonst
bleibt die Nacht milder bei meist sieben
bis vier Grad die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen zwischen 6 Grad in den
östlichen Mittelgebirge und 12 Grad am
Rhein der Regen der Nacht zieht morgen
über Tag weiter ostwärts erreicht dann
auch Berlin Brandenburg die Lausitz und
aus Bayern hinter dem Regen lockern die
Wolken hier im Nordwesten wieder auf bei
südwestend und es regnet kräftig weiter
bis Samstagabend können zum Beispiel
hier im Sauerland oder auch im
Schwarzwald bis zu 100 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter fallen es bleibt also sehr
verregnet in den nächsten Tagen es gibt
kaum mal Sonnenschein und dazu ist es
nach wie vor sehr windig guten Abend